so it's idea about 10 years ago that we
actually get insights the way humans
make decisions if we took blood and look
for markers of brain activity and so
this led to me having a giant freezer
full of blood products in my office so
my Dean called this vampire economics
I started this area neuro economics
because I was trying to understand why
countries are poor and I had found that
late 90s that levels of interpersonal
trust were among the strongest
predictors economist have ever found to
understand why poor countries are poor
and don't grow and why rich countries
stay rich so rich friend juries are by
and large high trust countries the
question was once you understand the
environmental conditions that produce
trust why would you ever trust a
stranger and so we designed this
experiment that came out of Vernon
Smith's work experiment onyx in which
you could send money to a stranger make
it grow and then that stranger could
either keep all the money and return it
to the first person
so the standard trust game has people
coming to lab sitting partition booths
so they have a lots of a privacy they
give it a secret number so their data
are anonymous and there's no deception
they're paid in cash at the end of the
experiment by someone who's not involved
in experiment by a cashier so everyone's
matched in pairs randomly you can't see
that person's you've been matched to you
can't talk to him or her everyone gets
ten bucks for showing up for sitting
these hard wooden chairs for an hour and
a half within each pair there's a first
decision maker and a second decision
maker and after lots of instruction the
first decision maker is prompted by
computer to take some of his or her ten
dollars and ship it to the person
they've been matched to whatever they
choose to ship comes out of their
account but gets tripled in the other
person's account alright so if you give
up say eight of your ten dollars you
keep two they just got twenty four
dollars plus the 10 bucks they got for
showing up so second person gets a
prompt by computer saying hey person one
sent you twenty-four dollars your total
is 34 do you want to send some amount
back to the first person we find is
about ninety percent of first decision
makers will send money and ninety-five
percent of those who receive money
returned more than they've received
the five percent of people who never
reciprocate in these kind of money
exchange experiments so their
unconditional non reciprocate errs lots
of syllables what do we really call them
on my lab we call them bastards we have
study people who are sexually abused or
abandoned and if you have enough abuse
as a child the brain areas that are
needed to process oxytocin don't develop
properly so you have this kind of
acquired psychopathology
before 10 years ago oxytocin was only
known to be active in the human female
during breastfeeding as sex and released
by both sexes during sex that was it
reproductive hormone found it's not just
a female hormone both males and females
produces in the appropriate settings
when it's time to cooperate when it's
time to trust a stranger when it's time
to reciprocate so we really have a
biology for reciprocation coupled with
that is testosterone which gives us the
biology of punishment and so it's those
two sides of the coin that let's balance
appropriate social behaviors humans
touch a lot so we did a study where we
showed that touch induces oxytocin
release and so you know you have to
believe your own research so I began
putting that research into practice by
refusing to shake hands with people and
hugging everybody
right so we've shown that the more money
you receive in this so-called trust game
when someone shown they trust you in a
tangible way and that's key for these
experiments the more your brain pumps
out oxytocin and those higher oxygen
levels are correlated with how much
money you've returned so I think one of
the values of this work to economics is
it provides a new foundation to
understand why people are doing what
they're doing so in this trust game
economists would say that individuals
are irrational because they were
returning money to a stranger but in
fact the irrational people walked out
the lab with more money than those who
are quote rational what I've tried to do
in my work is to provide the biological
foundation for human behavior
when you have the opportunity in some
sense the luxury to induce oxytocin
release and other people that causes
them to be empathic it's that empathy
that allows us to modulate our behavior
to the environment we're in and so we go
from Adam Smith's Theory of Moral
Sentiments to the wealth of nations it's
this empathy license understand others
which leads to more behavior which leads
to trust which leads to a greater number
of economic transactions at lower
transaction costs slay most business
deals even mergers of big corporations
work on a handshake where the lowers are
going to work out the details but you've
got to want to actually follow through
on this because what happens if you
don't hmm we're social creatures
reputation they say oh that guy is not a
fair dealer I'm not going to do business
with him anymore you can't induce your
own brain to release oxytocin you can
only give this to somebody else so if
you give this gift our biology has set
us up that people return it to us you've
got to give love to get love and you've
got to give it freely if you do that
he'll come back to you many folds